celle de lille ce soir pour ça que moi
les spice girls mais pour vous j'ai des
beatles
mama pas trahir
[Musique]
carla et kevin sont avec l'eau merci
d'être là vous êtes le couple star de la
télé réalité même jean bessis à y rester
pour pouvoir
il adore les marseillais c'est vrai que
les marseillais si la télé réalité qui
cartonnait le plus alors c'est un petit
peu en baisse ces dernières saisons mais
ça marche toujours assez fort après il
faut savoir que les autres marchent pas
trop non plus c'est vrai les autres
telairity la modernité ça marche que moi
j'en moyen de le doubler marseille mais
les marseillais sont loin de la soirée
bat déjà merci d'être là tous les deux
merci à toi bon vous allez ça va super
vous êtes heureux tous les deux tout va
bien avec maintenant que vous êtes
ensemble maintenant déclarés ou pas
déclarés il y avait un bail avant voici
3 3 en or ta maison vous avez fait dans
ces années depuis 1 623 c'est vrai vous
êtes séparés combien de temps ça a été
compliqué mais ça y est c'est bon là six
mois parce il y trois mois par la whey
jeter au marbre par les gens mais est
hors ue j'ai un résultat les collections
beitia c'est incroyable ce mec c'est
frais et printanier
alors les marseillais est ce que vous
allez rester dans les bars et aux pays
bas
bah en fait c'est une fois la question
fatale et répondu en fait bien sûr ouais
ça assez dans l'application les vite
répondu la même question à vitry pour le
jeu ben en fait non non clairement on a
décidé d'arrêter sa découverte saison
vous étiez dans sept ans sept ans carla
six ans édition compliqué quand même là
bas on s'est connu là bas on a et on a
tout fait on a une petite fille mène
anciens parce qu'on s'est connu la balle
je cours et je donnais marseillais
programme touche pas à mon poste
du coup on fait cela on a décidé de
prendre cette décision
j'ai pas facile quand même parce que
quand ça fait sept ans que tu fais la
même chose c'est dur de prendre cette
décision était bien avec cette
production
franchement c'était ces tests est
vraiment bien être pour vous arrêter
parce que je pense que pour notre bien
personnelle c'est la chose à faire
après comme j ai vraiment n'était ils
ont été vraiment cool avec nous c'est
l'accent sur la production que ce soit
pas gars qu'on adore julian rivage ici
car on les adore aussi à moi ya pas de
bruit entre vous ça n'a pas été une
décision facile après à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on a vraiment tout donné
dans cette famille des marseillais
maintenant on a aussi envie de penser à
nous il aurait voulu nous revoir là pour
les prochaines aventures mais c'est une
décision qu'on a prise ensemble qu'on a
mûrement réfléchi et on s'est dit c'est
peut-être le bon moment de partir pour
faire autre chose quelque chose qui nous
correspond à nous quelque chose
peut-être de mieux pour nous comment
vous l'avez annoncé la production aux
anciens les anciens camarades pour tout
dire je les ai dit cas pas cas d'accord
mais parce que c est lui carrément que
je suis vraiment les jours avec après
les autres on a préféré en parler
directement à la production pour leur
dire il était déçu la production essayer
de vous retenir ou pas oui après c'est
compréhensible ça fait sept ans qu'on
fait ça et va alors à nous ça fait dix
ans ouais mais pas tous mais même après
cela nous restions oui il ya un pote à
moi qui me demande qui de vous deux vous
demander si le mec a mis la c1 tarbes a
ou pas
[Rires]
bien sûr non c'est égal mais camilla ils
répondent à leurs toitures de patin
j'adore le but vous êtes triste de
quitter l'émission pas aussi nul c'est
une libération non rebâtir un peu triste
de quitter en fait non plus sous à la
plus un peu le groupe qu'on avait et
comme j'ai dit en fait c'est vraiment ce
qui est la production et/ou avec qui on
s'entendait vraiment bien après je pense
que pour nous c'était le moment de
partir voilà on va pas se mentir c'est
solide et ça tant qu on fait ça on
apprécie les super année c'était
magnifique mais je pense que voilà c'est
ce moment opportun pour voir si c'est
super dur je te qu'on ne l'est pas parce
que c'était bien payé c'était plaisant à
faire
ouais oui bernard très bien savoir si
vous aviez un contrat est ce que vous
êtes arrivé à échéance de ce contrat ou
pas loin de là c'est un homme de
contrats justes pour ça il en a pas
bonne question et la réponse donc ben
écoute main papon pour l'instant non
pour l'instant on n'est pas à échéance
d'accord vous leur devez quelque chose
encore non non le concept est sous
contrat jusqu'à quand enfin fin 2001
c'est sa voix un peu moins d'accord un
peu moins d'accord aujourd'hui vous
n'ayez pas peur de rien de petit et pas
parce que c'est vrai que si on se dit
vous gagnez très bien votre vie vous
être relayée sur les réseaux sociaux
donc vous gagnez très bien pour les
placements de produits etc
est ce que vous disent pas c'est pas un
risque de quitter cette aventure ou s'il
a fait notre succès qui a fait sa
notoriété qui a c'est totalement un
risque c'est totalement et c'est
l'émission qui cartonne le plus c'est
l'émission la plus regardée
on est là grâce à eux parce que c'est
sûr elle n'aurait pas dû devenir j'étais
serveurs au bazar pas pourquoi pas du
coup voilà c'est un risque à prendre
après je pense que pour nous c'est la
meilleure chose à faire
si ben on le regrettera peut être coupé
ils ont été en danger si vous avez c'est
y rester dans les maritimes n'ont pas du
tout ce pas pour votre couple non non
pas du tout vous êtes assez solide
ces différentes et gêne quand on n'est
pas dans paris voilà peut-être quand on
a une main d'enfant parce que ben
forcément tu t'amuses que c'est dur
aussi d'être épié 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 et de montrer sa vie 24 sur
24 7 jours 7 que c'est un truc vous en
avez marre aussi peut-être non c'est ce
qu'on va continuer à faire celui-ci m'a
filmée l'accouchement de
bien sûr non mais c'est rigolo ça ça
reste eh oui mais est ce que on parle de
sommes astronomiques dans l'univers des
influenceurs est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
êtes à l'abri pour vous arrêter
est ce qu'on ne peut travailler
non on a toujours besoin de travailler à
présent gagner de l'argent mais vous
pourriez vous voyez freiner ou pas mais
en deux journées c'est pas notre but
c'est pas d'arrêter parce que c'est
quelque chose qui nous plaît
comme en plus nous voilà on est on aime
bien partager un petit peu tout ce qu'on
fait et voilà quand je pense que je
pense que si on arrête quelque chose
pour commencer quelque chose note donc
ça vraiment pas vous dit on va faire
autre chose c'est quoi entre chaud alors
justement avoir parlé dans un instant
pas vous arrêter vous êtes malin
justement vous sentez l'air du temps et
vous sentez que c'est la fin de ce genre
de programme
franchement je pense pas chaque année
ils disent que c'est la fin au final ça
continue après c'est vrai qu'il ya
énormément de coupe maintenant qu'ils
ont fait leur propre famille donc c'est
vrai que je suis franchement je pense
que ça c'est une masse est une marque
qui marche oui mais quand j ça va
s'arrêter ça va s'arrêter
bien sûr il s'arrête jamais je pense que
ça ratera pas non plus avec moi tous les
ans on dit ça va s'arrêter ça va
s'arrêter
elle est toujours là il ya une rumeur
qui circule depuis quelque temps sur les
réseaux sociaux concernant une deuxième
grossesse c'est pas vrai non pas moi en
tout cas
[Rires]
mais on réfléchit à avoir un deuxième
enfant mais ce ne sera pas pour tout de
suite
oui valérie benaïm qu'est-ce qu'il va
vous manquer de cette aventure que vous
que vous arrêtez maintenant est-ce que
vous avez déjà anticipé en disant ça je
sais c'est un truc qui va me manquer les
peut-être les copains ou peut-être pas
autre changement le ski nous et qui fait
c'est vraiment de partir en tournage
ce que ça soit comme vous dit que ça
fait quand ça fait sept ans qu'on fait
ça comme vous par exemple avec la
production de l'est connaissaient tous
donc en voiture on voit tout le temps tu
es amis tu pars en vacances avec tes
amis et ça fait toujours plaisir si on
est content à chaque fois de faire ce
genre d'aventuré donc oui ça ça va ça
peut nous manquer gilles est ce que vous
tournez en rond dans les marseillais est
ce que vous vous disiez on n'est pas au
bout de l'aventuré c'est peut-être un
peu moins bien pour nous ça marche un
peu moins bien je pense pas je pense
juste que voilà des fois c'est quand on
est bien dans une place dans un job des
fois mais si on se plante et challenge
je me suis dit pourquoi pas partir sur
autre chose c'est le bon moment
voilà un petit peu de renouveau de
nouveautés et de risque aussi des fois
c'est bien de prendre des risques dans
la vie
voilà c'est tout alors aujourd'hui donc
vous avez quitté cette aventure on n'est
toujours pas mariés tous les deux non
parce qu'il paraît que ça fait ouais ça
fait plusieurs fois vous de vous marier
à chaque fois c'est repoussé à une
pandémie mondiale
ah oui j'avais marqué on devait se
marier lala au mois de mai et au final
on a reporté au final on sait pas mais
voilà c'est là c'était beau ouais bon
c'est toujours la bague à savage il
gardait aussi des lavages
il a revendu alors j'aide des véritables
stars sur les réseaux sociaux qu'ils
étudient pour par plusieurs millions de
personnes
honnêtement c'est vrai que ça a été
beaucoup dit aujourd'hui vous avez pas
peur que d'être mon suivi si vous parlez
des marchés parce que c'est ça coûte ça
peu après il est revenu
franchement il ya plein de personnes qui
ne font pas télé ou télé réalité qui
s'en est ensuivie énormément
on va dire que maintenant il y en a qui
font de la télé qui sont pas suivies du
tout il ya c'est vrai il appellerait
je suis pas me fatiguer très peur mais
c'est bon stéphane adam premier degré
oui les maires un compte instagram way
son bébé quand tu me fais ça tu évoques
chacun oui c'est vrai qu'il à 995m
abonnez vous ouais c'est incroyable
pouvait pas les boules
j'ai un peu plus à faire et ce parce que
tu as les yeux petit mais écrivait dans
le petit filet alors qu'est ce que vous
allez faire maintenant c'est ça que tout
le monde envie de savoir
il est 21h neuf on en dirait vous
quittez des marseillais mais qu'est ce
que vous allez faire c'est quoi vos
projets ben écoute on sait que ben
c'était dans l'air du temps qui ont
quitté les marseillais c'est vrai que du
coup on a eu pas mal de quitter la
production aussi bonifié prod non mais
je sais pas ça reste on vous restez avec
nous ouais d'accord m'explique pas ce
que ça j'ai pas trop bien compris mais
en gros gros et non oui et non on a en a
on a envie de faire plein de choses et
bateaux courts en plus donc bien sûr
alors ils vont travailler avec avec
notre production
oui h2o productions donc pour travailler
sur un nouveau projet vous pouvez dire
c'est vous qui êtes venus me voir pour
me proposer le projet raconte elle aux
téléspectateurs c'est vrai quand on y
est on a été approché par pas mal de dot
production pour faire pas mal de choses
c'est que nous à la base on vous
conseille pas ce qu'on allait faire et
on s'était vu juste après patients carla
était passé et du coup jeté été proposés
clairement de savoir si ça pouvait
intéresser de faire quelque chose autour
de nos nations et jeu court on en a
discuté et on va faire votre mariage
voilà voilà
avec plusieurs idées concepts par l'
exode prêtre est un père leur mariage
moi j'étais plus jeune je produisais
départ 12h20 attentionné mariale non
mais et il est un concept que j'adore
c'est vrai que il va y avoir que vous
pouvez raconter à côté vous c'est votre
truc je t'en prie vous êtes non mais en
gros en gros c'est simple suivre notre
notre vie notre notre mariage avec nos
amis et à plein de plein de choses qui
vont se passer aussi entre nous et le
but c'est vraiment de suivre notre
mariage mais en même temps tous nos amis
qui sont avec nous m c'est va être
plutôt rigolo après je me suis vraiment
dit le garçon est un garçon d2 voilà
exactement
il ya beaucoup mieux sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est qu'ils nous posent des
questions et si on peut en avoir
d'ailleurs en direct nordine si oui se
réveiller merci juste est-ce que vous
partez pas ce que les gens disent est ce
que ce qui a eu des embrouilles
suite aux différentes affaires non pas
du tout bien sûr qu'il ya eu des en gros
c'est pour ça qu'on n'avait pas ou pas
du tout non pas du tout pas des
précisions en revanche on sait que même
si on serait revenu certes on aurait eu
encore des embrouilles mais au final
corne enfermés dans une maison même
place aux 24 on se réconcilie c'est
comme ça c'est vraiment une décision
qu'on a mûrement réfléchie qu'on s'est
dit maintenant à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
est ce que cette histoire c'est pas venu
au bon moment pour rebondir sur autre
chose
je pense qu à rien sans rien dans la vie
si c'est tomber maintenant c'est
peut-être pour se diriger vers autre
chose et c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire quand vous avez envie de faire un
nouveau truc vous avez cette nouvelle
mairie sont en fait voilà vous voyez pas
dans une maison encore wayne on sait pas
ce qu'on a on a vraiment envie de passer
à autre chose voilà ça fait sept ans je
pense qu'on a tout donné pour sa part
cette émission on a vraiment vraiment
tout donné pour le gault et et voilà je
pense que c'est pour nous c'est le bon
moment de d'essayer de 2 ouais on est
heureux c'est cette nouvelle aventure
qui démarre
on est très heureux mais il a peur de
travailler avec la production h2o fille
jean mais c'est ce que vous avez une
question c'est à dire les poser mais
j'ai pas eu de rythme en réponse
d'accord la légende chez commence qu'en
bas aucune idée on notera voilà vous
savez qui sont exclues comme ils ont dit
jusque au niveau de nos prochains mois
prochain alors si cette question oui moi
mes enfants vous regarde pas encore
regardé regarde les marseillais et le
problème des marseillais sait que je
trouve que il parle pas très bien
français
je reçois mes enfants qui commencent à
voir des formations linguistiques qui
sont pour le moins gênante
donc je me demandais si vul influence
que vous avez il pourrait pas y avoir un
canal d' influence plus positive sur
leur mode d'expression
la richesse de leur vocabulaire enfin
quelque chose qui soit un peu par
exemple jambe par exemple le cas
l'expression vous choque pas par exemple
quand on dit manille ou le copain à
quelqu'un tout ça c'est des fautes de
français
est ce que vous avancez c'était que ça
ça va ça si je suis je suis je si je
serai à la plage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une plage linguistique l'a
complètement alors il ya une question
une dernière question avant qu'on les
récentes affaires autour de la
téléralité prostitution drogue ont-ils
été at il motivé votre décision
tiens c'est bien ça vincent pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout et je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites qui sont pas la réalité aussi de
ce qui se passe donc j'avais
l'impression carrément que c'était des
débats d'abord des limites quand
j'entendais parler c'est pas ça plutôt
désordre voulait dans tous les cas nous
on était là-bas c'était pas ça et lui
confirmer sa très belle salle j tous
n'ont rien à voir non merci en tout cas
vous souhaite du bonheur